[Music]
[Applause]
one of our favorite guests Joey Votto
the Reds first baseman six-time All-Star
won the MVP back in 2010 and now he's a
fan
I mean not a fan of this show I'm just
talking about he was a fan at the
Ballpark he's uh out with a shoulder
surgery you were you were trending on
Twitter there uh Joey uh how was this
planned that you were going to go and be
a fan and watch the game
hi Dan hi Julie
I am a fan of your show
I uh it just it all came about I so
I've thrown a Pittsburgh Pirates of
Roberto Clemente Jersey when I was
accepting the uh nomination for the
Cincinnati Reds
um and I felt guilt
I felt guilt that I had a pirates Jersey
on so I was like I gotta take this
jersey off
it's the right thing to do with where
the Jersey
but I needed to give it to a fan so I
was like all right
I've never been out I've been in the
stands before I'm gonna head up we're
gonna give the Clemente Jersey to a
young fan I'm going to sign I had a Reds
21 also I'm allowed to wear 21 because
I'm a Clemente nominee
um I signed that one I'm gonna go give
it to a fan so I head upstairs
and I go to the entryway and I'd always
like imagined hoped uh that one day I
would be able to interact with the fans
kind of during my career but I'm playing
and I'm injured right now so I had the
opportunity so I head up to the front
Gates the security I walk outside
and there's a little one there and I
give her the Clemente Jersey and she was
appreciative and then I crossed paths
with a with another Reds fan and I give
my jersey to and so I'm I'm there I
start taking pictures start signing
autographs
and then I just decide this feels okay
this feels safe people are reacting well
I'm going to keep going so I've never
been to the 500 section before I head
upstairs I go to the 500 section what
have you I've never seen a Reds game
before I've never interacted with the
Reds fans mid game
I get down there I go behind home play I
go into the right field bleachers left
field bleachers Walk The Concourse you
know the reactions I got made it
worthwhile so
um it just all came so quickly
but did you get people who well the
reactions were what I because I'm gonna
guess they're like you you kind of look
like Joey Votto but you can't be Joey
Votto lots of that there was a lot of
Red Sox fans and uh most of them looked
at me and were like dude show me your
ticket what is this even your seat
uh but the Reds fans were excited and
you know I got a lot of that you look
like Joey and then when eventually I
think there was like message around the
stadium maybe at about the halfway point
when I hit the right field bleachers for
sure when I hit the right field
bleachers which was like Mark number
three uh that's when people knew oh
Joey's in the stands right now and uh
they they were so they were so welcoming
so excited to see me so and I was
excited to see them
it was cool
I mean it just was because you're able
to you don't get to see it's almost like
an actor who gets to go on the other
side of the camera and and they get to
see what the director see you get to sit
there with the fans to see what that is
like and as you said you'd never done
that before but growing up
how many baseball games did you go to
phew few few you know from 1314 on
baseball kept me busy
I remember you know maybe a couple here
and there
um but not many games and not that was
the appeal to me
you know I I love going to a baseball
game and I'm in the middle of my career
and every day when I'm playing I'm in a
completely different frame of mind you
know I've I'm I'm locked in on my work
not my teammates I wanted to support my
teammates but they're doing their own
work I'm so I'm locked in on how well
the team plays and how well I play over
and over and over and you become robotic
when it comes to your interactions with
the fans signing autographs smiling for
a picture signing on around smiling for
a picture over and over and over and
over and you can't let your guard down
because you have to save that stamina
you have to save that that energy for
performance that night recovery at night
game the next day over and over and over
and so it's important to me to connect
with the fans but it's it's also
important to protect my energy whereas
yesterday I was able to completely let
my guard down and connect with the fans
the only thing I had to do is protect my
shoulder but
um it was such a different experience
because I'm still in the heart of my
career I think at this stage I'm
recognizing that
it's going to end at some point I'm not
sure when but you know I just turned 39
and and you're I'm much much closer to
the end than I am I am even the middle
or beginning and
um so to me I wanted another thing too I
want people to the fans to know who I am
like it's a little different when you're
a former player and you enter the crowd
you can sit in your seat and watch the
game and they're like we didn't get to
see you play whereas I'm walking around
and there's Votto jerseys you know
there's people you know that watch me
play just a month ago in live so I I
don't know why it just appealed to me
and just watching a game
I got to sit with a couple fans for a
bit take it in taking the angle it was
just uh it was a really Charming
experience for me we're talking to Joey
Votto second consecutive year he's the
Reds nominee for baseball's prestigious
Roberto Clemente award
a couple of analysts at ESPN a couple of
you know very short baseball guys said
that what Aaron judge is doing could be
could be the greatest baseball season of
all time
what do you think
I think it's a very fair statement
I do think without getting too deep into
the weeds with the doping stretch I
think that was
a much different era I also think post
integration
I think that matters there's too many
big wins above replacement Seasons too
much too many extreme seasons in uh the
earlier part of the 20th century
um you know it's
it's nice that you put up a 12-win
season or hit 400 but you did it against
a bunch of what you know white players
that you know weren't competing against
the best of the world whereas you know
the two American League candidates are a
Japanese player and a six foot nine you
know black athlete in Aaron judge and so
to me we have the very best version of
the game right now with the best
athletes and Aaron judges completely
dominating us
um 60 home runs
running for the Triple Crown fantastic
Defender
uh uh uh he's he's the leader of the
Yankees and um
uh just purely offensively you know
measurably he's in that upper upper tier
of of offensive one-year performances
and
um I think it's very fair to say that he
is having the greatest offensive season
of all time
I David Cone on yesterday former pitcher
works for the Yankees and he said that
the baseballs are they're not lively
anymore
so are they I'm trying to understand if
baseball wants more home runs because
the analytics say go up there and swing
for home runs that's what you do
offensively but baseball bought Rawlings
they bought the baseballs
and now are they are they less Lively
are they deadened like your assessment
well in in game yes they are they're
they don't fly as well
um you know just just recently I was
looking at the Home Run statistics and I
think the last five years or so there
the average was somewhere around one two
one three home runs per game 1.2 1.3
lots of
um lots of big home run seasons over the
last five six years since 2015 this year
big dip and I think that is what makes
Aaron's season to you know call back his
season uh special but the experience of
being a hitter now when you strike a
ball kind of misstrike a ball
uh and it's getting caught at the wall
that forces you as a hitter to adjust
because we're we're not going to just
keep going out there and coming up short
we're gonna
lower our trajectory to more guarantee a
hit a line drive double or single
um maybe we'll move closer to the
corners either foul pole meaning we'll
try to pull the ball but with the
shorter part of the field so there's
many different ways you can go about it
maybe more bunting more Hitting and
Running I I think there's a chance that
and another thing I forgot to mention
more putting the ball in play you know
you swing and take a you take a big
swing attempting a home run
it comes with risk swing and Miss risk
whereas
if you attempt to control the barrel and
make contact
in play
you your home run likelihood goes down
but singles doubles all the other
options but our judges hitting 60 home
runs
and baseball doesn't want you to hit 60
home runs
that's incredible
he's he's having a special season for a
reason if he hits 62.
who was the single season all-time home
run champ
um
so for me Barry Bonds was my favorite
hitter
um
but I can't ignore all the facts
um I will say I will say I'm rooting
hard for Aaron judge to hit as many home
runs as possible
uh Dan this is the worst question to ask
me right now because I'm still in
uniform
and uh I think maybe post career I'll be
able to answer that question but no
again it's just too just too difficult
to answer no I get it and you're not
retiring by the way
guess Joey Votto is one of two active
players with at least 2 000 hits 1300
walks and also second among all active
players
um on base percentage do you know the
only other active player who has a
better on base percentage than you Joe
Ivano Mike Trout yeah yeah just barely
Ah that's not bad anytime you're
mentioned with Mike Trout
that's pretty good yeah it's good and
you thought he wasn't a Hall of Famer
last time well he's not yet yeah but it
was not like it wasn't like who's a Hall
of Famer right now when we were talking
about hypothetical Hall of Fame no he's
going to be a Hall of Famer but you
didn't think that at the time you were
having your doubts
when did I say I had my doubts about
Mike Trout being a Hall of Famer you
know last time I came on you said
hey it's so good to have Joey for the
first time I'd been on two times before
Dan Patrick
and now you're forgetting the Mike Trout
conversation yeah but those were
forgettable appearances
[Laughter]
yeah we forgot about those those weren't
good yeah you're right I'm on uh with
Max Kellerman next so I'll I'll be sure
to forget this I like that I like that
by the way
uh so there's two active players with at
least 2 000 hits 1300 walks the other
one Albert Pujols oh yeah
big year for Albert pools
okay
62 home runs for judge
700 home runs for pool holes you get to
pick one
more important this year well this year
it's the Home Run Record but all time
it's clearly Albert I mean there's four
he'll be the fourth with Willie babe and
Barry oh excuse me the fifth with Hank
Aaron obviously
um but for me for me I'm in the I'm in
the National League Central and I played
against Alberta's best and I well you
know I watched him leave and watched him
come back and the excitement uh the
support the Cardinals fans give him and
also the full circle nature of of his
experience in St Louis I I love it I'm
so happy for him
I think that what you did going in the
stands should be something that other
players do if you're on the DL
as long as you can walk around and you
not get injured
and you know nobody's going to Pat you
on the shoulder and say hey great job
great senior or anything like that what
do you think other players if you're on
the DL that you have to have one night
where you go and visit the the well why
why you're cringing why well no not have
to well no we we would encourage you
we're gonna call it doing a Vato
I think that it was something I was
excited to do and I felt equipped to do
and
um we recently got done with a a
collective bargaining agreement and we
did not negotiate that interview
so our players our union doesn't come on
come on we don't have to do anything
we'll call it already gotten enough vato
tearing you know instead of hearing
follow volunteering it's Auto tiering
hey I like that okay I mean that's off
the cuff is what that was I mean off
speed off speed off off the rotator cuff
off yeah
um hey great to talk to you is this the
first time we've had Joey on first time
yeah man great appearance yeah are we
even recording right now no no no this
is not this is a practice session live
this is live you were live yes I had
some things that for sure would have got
me canceled had I said them oh my
goodness do you think I could get a
pitch by you right now
yes okay
okay I just wanted to make sure I've got
one arm
I got one arm too
all right was that a play on words I've
got one arm two
uh well good luck with Max Kellerman I'm
sure it'll be as as fun
I'm not going on with Max color oh now
you're refusing to he he by the way what
was the whole thing with him uh saying
Albert's thing was oh yeah what was that
all about
well he said I want what he's having
insinuating that Albert could be uh
spiced up there a little bit there it's
called the hot takes if you ever get in
the media don't fall prey to saying
something just to get a hot take to get
reaction or get likes just I don't think
that I don't think that was a hot take I
think he meant it meant it oh yeah I do
too but yeah I do but he had to walk it
back yeah yeah no Albert I I don't know
I'm not I'm not Albert but watching him
in Anaheim and watching him now in St
Louis he's paced his his schedule he
doesn't play as much he's matched up
against left-hand I'll say this one more
thing before I go confidence and Rhythm
are like important for a hitter and in
July he was hitting a buck 90 with no
damage no damage I think sub 400 slug
maybe even right around 300 slug not a
strong stretch but there's something
about when you uh time a good matchup
and then you'd repeat it and then you
start believing that that's a reality
and I think he did that with left-handed
pitching for a bit and then when you hit
this rhythm
all of a sudden you can start doing it
Taking Chances start doing it against
different because he's starting to doing
that's right-handed pitching you start
doing it against both sides Taking
Chances and I think he just he's so
strong naturally so would you rather
witness 700 be at that game or 62 for
Judd yeah probably 700 just because of
my relationship with the Cardinals fans
you know my lawyer accountant uh
financial advisor all there you know
they pour the wine and we you know chop
up the St Louis Cardinals fans are hard
on me at times you know they the
Cardinal fans aren't hard on anybody oh
they are
sneaky sneaky sneaky they are yep
well uh great to have you on good luck
with the recovery I appreciate it and uh
I don't know what do you think should we
have Joey on maybe again sometime
absolutely tomorrow oh nice I'll see you
guys next time for the first time okay
thank you Joey
that's Joey Votto fan